la presidenta Dina boluarte le dijo a la
organización de los Estados Americanos
que no va a Rendirse ante los grupos
autoritarios que tratan de imponerse en
el Perú aprovechando su presentación
virtual ante la oea Dina boluarte le
respondió a los presidentes de chile
Gabriel boric y de Colombia Gustavo
Petro quienes criticaron a su gobierno y
les dijo qué salida están planteando
frente a la crisis del Perú una salida a
la violencia o una salida a la paz y la
democracia les preguntó a los
mandatarios boluarte fue enfática al
solicitar aloea el apoyo para la
realización en Perú de los próximos
comicios presidenciales libres y
transparentes en esa línea remarcó que
le ha solicitado al congreso de este
país el adelanto de los comicios y
repitió que espera el apoyo de los
países en la región
Francisco en otras noticias de Perú qué
reacciones ha generado el envío de
fuerzas militares a puno al sur del país
en medio de la extensión del toque de
queda en esta región
precisamente para un sector de esta
nación ha resultado extraño que mientras
Dina boluarte hace un llamado a los
peruanos a una tregua nacional para
establecer mesas de diálogo que
propicien conversaciones en los
distintos actores sociales de este
conflicto nacional y se busque solución
y paz y al mismo tiempo hay enviado
alrededor de 500 soldados con vehículos
militares a la región puno que se
encuentra en el sur del Perú y que es
precisamente el corazón de las protestas
pero al mismo tiempo otros sectores del
país señalan que ya era hora que la
presidenta boluarte ponga orden en el
país porque ellos manifiestan que las
protestas los bloqueos los disturbios
que se producen en distintos puntos del
país que están afectando aeropuertos
bloqueando el tren borroqueando las
carreteras
dañando comisarías juzgados fiscalías y
toda propiedad pública y peruana le
estaría cobrando una alta factura
los sectores económicos están señalando
que todo este conflicto estaría
generando enormes pérdidas económicas a
esta nación que ascenderían a más de mil
millones de dólares por otro lado la
superintendencia nacional de transportes
está señalando que el tránsito Aún es
crítico en este país a este momento se
reportan 90 puntos de tránsito en el
país interrumpido y 20 vías nacionales
afectadas los peruanos ya están
comenzando a sentir una crisis en lo que
se refiere al desabastecimiento de
alimentos y combustible y está
encareciendo los productos de diverso
tipo de servicios y también de alimentos
para las amas de casa
enrareciendo el transporte y alterando
la vida de los peruanos